you will burn the Santa Blanca drug
cartel to the ground but no one will
know who was holding a match Ghost Recon
wildlands beta signups are happening
right now if you're looking to join the
ghost unit and take down the Santa
Blanca cartel you don't want to go in
blind
so let's comb through some of the videos
and blog posts Ubisoft has released and
talked about five things you definitely
need to know number one
ubisoft's biggest map ever wildlands is
set in Bolivia and Ubisoft says it's the
biggest world that's ever created thanks
to a report at polygon we've gotten our
first look at the map and yeah it's
pretty huge it covers 21 different
regions across the country and the 11
different biomes range from mountains to
jungles to swamps to Santa Blanca
encampments with 26 different bosses to
take down across the map there's plenty
of opportunity to explore and shoot
number 2 weapon collection and
customization speaking of shooting a ub
blog post informs us that there are 50
guns for your ghosts to unlock and equip
including some hard-to-find exotic
weapons wildlands gives you quote two
primary weapons and a secondary firearm
assault rifles machine guns shotguns and
sniper rifles are just a few of the
primary arms you can equip and
secondaries like pistols and compact
smg's give you an extra layer of
firepower even better the gunsmith is
returning from Future Soldier with a
bunch of new options you can customize
your guns with over a hundred
attachments like different paints scopes
and stocks some of them even add new
functions like suppression or alternate
firing modes number three character
creation it's not just your guns getting
the custom treatment
Ubisoft posted a customization trailer
that showed off a ton of options for
creating your own unique ghost look this
includes changing your face hair
fatigues accessories and even tattoos
Ubisoft said at another post that quote
killing high-value targets and
completing other special in-game events
can all contribute to your inventory of
customization items so as you take down
Santa Blanca
your ghost will look more and more like
a reflection of your personal play style
number four co-op play so you've got the
load out in the look but you can also
decide how to approach Bolivia's massive
world you can go it alone
but as the UB blog confirms taking down
the whole cartel is more fun with a
squad of friends who can all upgrade
their own ghosts you and your buddies
can divvy up responsibilities during
missions coordinate stealth takedowns
fly everyone in a chopper and even
convoy up your vehicles for a full-on
assault alternatively you can play with
three AI partners and synchronize your
takedowns in some ways that might
actually be better than getting trolled
by your friends number five stealth
tactics of course if you want to take a
stealthy approach to the missions there
are plenty of tricks at your disposal
thanks to a full mission walkthrough
video from the developer we've gotten a
good look at how to stay quiet during
infiltrations there are the obvious
suppressors you can toggle on and off on
your weapons
but elements like the weather also come
into play rain will obscure enemy vision
and cover up the sound of footsteps get
the drop on cartel soldiers and you can
knock them out and hide the body making
one less patrol route to worry about
future soldiers drone is back to help
you survey the area and you can even
hijack enemy vehicles to slip past
checkpoints really if you lose the
element of surprise that's on you all of
these features have been announced by
Ubisoft so you can expect even more
information to trickle out before the
game hits ps4 Xbox one and PC on March
7th 2017 and as I said before if you
want to play the game early you can sign
up for a chance to receive a beta code
on Ubisoft's website right now maybe
we'll see you in the field soldier until
then stay tuned to game spot for all the
latest on Ghost Recon wildlands